I'm Jennifer Fisher and I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on the office together and we're best friends. And now we're doing the ultimate office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of the office and give exclusive behind the scene stories that only two people who are there can tell you. We're the office ladies. Hello! Hey! Are you ready for a welcome party that no one asked for and no one wants to throw?
Well, I am. I'm also ready to haul some cube. Yeah, let's haul cube today. It's season 8 episode 20. This was written by Steve Healy and directed by Ed Helms. Here's your summary. After being instructed by Robert California to throw Nellie a welcome party, the group decides to prank her by making it intentionally awful.
Dwight and Jim reluctantly help Nellie move into her new apartment and they get a glimpse into her heartbreak. Meanwhile, Andy and Aaron have an important pit stop to make on their road trip back to Scranton. Andy is going to finally break up with Jessica. With Aaron, present. I know what to say. I have to say. We have texted about it.
We have feelings about it. We have strong feelings about it. Fast fact number one, guest star Brett Gellman as the magician. I need to just clap for a second. I need to clap for a second. I need to clap for a second. I love him. He was so fantastic.
We're going to talk a lot about it, but oh my gosh, did this guy make us laugh? I did not know Brett Gellman before he guest started on the office. He came in and we didn't know what to do with him. He was so funny. He destroyed us all. He did.
You guys out there probably recognize him from the gazillion things he's been in. He gets a lot of love for stranger things. I absolutely loved him in Fleabag and Love. Everything he did in Fleabag was perfection. I do have a crossover shout out. Oh, yes. Yes. Not Monk, but fresh off the boat. He played Dusty Nuggett, and I played Amy Chestnut.
So, did you guys work together? We did not. Oh, but we have a crossover moment, crossover connection. Well, before he was on the office, he had done a lot of shorts for funnier dye presents. This ran on HBO. Very short-lived. He had been on Kirby Arnthusiasm.
He had been on board to death. And it was our writer, Hallstead Sullivan, who pitched Brett for the role. He didn't know him personally, but he was a fan of his work. And one of the Funny or Die episodes he had recently done was a 16- one man musical called 1000 cats. It is really, really funny.
I watched it. Brett dresses as a black cat. He has a headband on with little black ears. It's very serious. Very serious. Brett did an interview where he said he had been doing it as a 30-minute live show at upright Citizensburgade for like eight years, and then it ended up on the Funnier Di HBO show.
The Funnier Di sketch opened with a video of his character talking about his stage show 1000 Cats and why it's important to the world. Oh my gosh, I think we should listen to it. Okay. One thousand cats is not a play. It's not a musical. It's not even really a performance. It is a universal consciousness that is physicalized
through me. Of course, the appropriate venue is not the theater that I will be performing it in. Really, there's only one venue that would do 1,000 cats justice, and that venue is the Vatican. I am performing 1,000 cats yet. I am not performing 1,000 cats, because 1,000 cats doesn't even exist while at the same time.
1000 cats is the only thing that exists. So then it cuts to the performance. I saw a part of the performance. It's amazing. It's 1,000 cats, but they have 9,000 lives and 9,000 stories and he's going to tell each one. Each one. And sing. Sing them. Yes. It's a musical. It's a musical. Did we mention it's a one-man musical about 1,000 cats? So Hallstead was familiar, and when they were breaking down the script, he said, I know who should play the magician. Allison Jones put him on tape.
Everybody watched this tape and loved him. And, you know, Ed Helms was the director of this when they gave Ed the tape. He was so excited because he had known Brett for years, you know, from their days of both doing upright citizens brigade. And he was like, yes, yes, he's the guy. I can't imagine anyone else playing this part.
And I'm sad we don't see more of him. I'm like, why couldn't someone have dated him on the show? Right? Right? Who would it have been? Angela? No, I don't think she would like anything to do with magic. She would date the 1 cats guy though maybe.
Would you be a true man who has a musical about 1000 cats? A hundred percent. I think so. All right, well, let's move on to fast fact number two. We had a very special cameo on this show that caused a fan mail flurry. We got so much mail about it. That cameo is the shoebox that Dwight and Jim find in Nellie's apartment. You know, Benjamin that holds all the photos of Henry. Yeah, it's her sad box. Yes. Let me explain why this caused a fan mail flurry. All of our letters
were from folks in the UK. First off, Becky O. from County Durham, England said, I noticed the shoe box is for the brand Clark's shoes. This is pure perfection. Clark's is such a well-known British shoe brand. I remember before a new school term, my mom would take me to Clark's and it would be so, so busy. You would have to get a ticket and have to wait till they called your ticket number for a foot measure and then choose your school shoes Any box could have been used for this But the commitment and attention to detail to use an iconic British high street brand was just perfection I am obsessed with this detail was this a fill shade decision. I cannot express how amazing
I think this kind of detail is that That is fantastic. I totally missed that. I missed it too. Oh my gosh, thank you for writing in about it. Annabee from Lancashire United Kingdom said, I need to know everything about the amazing shoebox choice in this episode. This is exactly where someone like Nelly would have bought her workshoes from. And Liam C. and Glasgow Scotland said, I love that Nellyie's box of photos
aka Benjamin was in a Clark shoe box. I have fond memories of my mom taking me to get my feet measured at the end of the summer before starting a new school year as always props to the prop department. So great. Well everyone, I checked the script and there was no mention of the kind of shoebox. This was 100% fill-shay, paying attention to detail. I love that it resonated with so many people. This is just a sample of the letters we got. And I love that the memories that brought back were people doing there before school shopping,
foot measure and shoe shopping. Yeah, I remember doing that going, there was one children shoe shoe store in the mall and you would go and get your foot measured and pick out a pair of sneakers or whatever. This is such a sweet memory and I love that Phil got it. He nailed it. Nailed it.
Well, I thought it might be fun to do a small deep dive on Clarks, this company that delighted people so much. Great. So here we go. Clarks is a company that delighted people so much. Great. So here we go. Clarks is a British international shoe manufacturer and retailer. It was founded in 1825 by Cyrus Clark
in the small village of Sweet Somerset, England. This is the most adorable small town. I looked at the picture. Of course. Of course. Yes. Of course. I want to go. I already course. I want to go.
I already know. I want to go. I know I do too. This town only has about 11,000 people living there, but the Clarks World Headquarters is still there. Love that. The company has about 1,400 branded stores and franchises around the world. You know there's one in our mall, but I wonder if it's the same company.
It has to be right. Now I'm excited to go there even more. The company is very well-known for their desert boot and their wallaby. The wallaby is what Walter White wore on Breaking Bad. And of course, children's school shoes. I am pretty sure that I wore clerks on the office. I think they do really comfy work shoes for the lady executive. You know, it's like a heel, but it's like a chunky heel, a chunky low heel with good arch support. I mean, we all know I wore sass.
And then the working man, they've got some nice loafers. I've been all over the website, clearly. But here's what I needed to know. Is there a Clark's factory that we can tour? Is it in England and that cute little town? No, that's where the headquarters are. No, there is no factory tour. I did find the Clark's shoe museum, but unfortunately, it closed in 2019 after 70 years. It just closed. I found a blog called Travel with Kevin and Ruth. Okay. There are Canadian couple who are in their early 60s. They've been married for 39 years and they blogged all about visiting the Clarks Shoomuseum. They have great photos.
But unfortunately, that's as close as we're gonna get, Ange. Can I please put Kevin and Ruth's blog link in our stories? Cause I'm sure they would be delighted. I would love to check it out myself. They have a great blog, they have lots of pictures, and they just travel all around. Amazing. Yeah. Maybe we should meet up with them somewhere in Kevin and Ruth.
Kevin and Ruth, we can be on our blog. All right, finally, fast back number three. Office ladies announcements. Yes. These announcements are based on some popular mailbag letters. Yes, they are. In our general mailbox. First off, Peyton from Georgia and many others sent in requests asking if we would please update
the Office ladies Instagram story highlight. I did it, guys. I did it. I sat down one day and updated them all. I'm sorry, I got a little behind. Yes. We are very excited to announce that all past episode stories are now available. So when you're listening and you hear us say,
we're gonna put it on the pod. You don't have to worry if you missed the day that we post it. Just go to the highlights. Go to the highlights. Next up, Angela, let's talk mugs. Okay, Suzanne in New York wants to know, where did they get Pam's pink mug on the show?
Suzanne wanted to know, Jenna was this mug originally yours? If so, where did you get it? Is there any brand on the bottom of the mug? I don't know where they got it, Suzanne. I looked, there's no logo anywhere on the mug. Everyone knows I still have it. It broke during season nine and they glued it back together for me. Perfectly. Yes. Perfectly. I can't drink coffee out of it because it will fall apart from the heat.
But now it's like a souvenir for you of your time on the office. And I love it. However, I did find a woman online who makes homemade pottery. She makes the Pam mug. I bought one from her. She didn't know it was me. I love it. I post about it all the time. It's made by Linda Renee pottery. I will link to her in our stories and you can find that in the now highlights. Jenna looked at me very pointedly and Angela, you will put it in. Will you highlight that? Yes, I will highlight Angela, you will put it in. Will you highlight that? Yes, I will highlight it. I will put it in stories.
Well, since we're on the subject of mugs, I want to plug if you have our office ladies merch mugs, Angela. They make great holiday gifts and I don't know if everybody out there is already thinking holidays, but I have a personal goal to get all of my holiday shopping done by December 15th. I want to be ahead this year, not kind. Okay. No end of the year scramble for gifts. No. Okay.
So anyway, we have a really adorable, it is your mug, mug. It's blue. It's so cute. The writing is etched. It's not printed on its etched. And it's that sort of light blue, and then the rim of it has like a little kind of brown
ceramic color. I want you guys to know we gave Steve Carell one of these when he came into studio. And he was like, this is a good mug. It is a good mug. Yeah, I love the shape. I love the size. I love it. I love holding it in my hand.
Mm-hmm. That's what she said. She said all that. She did. It's $35. We also have our icons mug which has little office related images on it. There's a little teapot and a little yogurt lid metal and spilled chili. That one's so cute. I love it. It's $15. And since we are
talking about the holidays early announcement, we are bringing back all of our ugly Christmas sweatshirts. They're really cozy including the party plan in committee one and we have other holiday stuff. We will post a link to all of our merch in our stories. Well done, lady. Thank you. And finally, Angela's journal. Lady, we got a lot of mail, a lot of requests. Melina from Idaho said, when is Angela gonna read from her journals again? It always makes me laugh out loud. Oh my gosh. So, Angie, I wrote you, I said, can you read from read from her journals again, it always makes me laugh out loud. Oh my gosh. So, Angie, I wrote you, I said, can you read
from your journal today? Yes, I can, I can. And guess what? I have some Angela journal updates for everyone. What are they? You know, we've been doing some home construction. And I haven't been able to get into our shed where we keep everything, right?
Finally got into the shed the other day. We're digging around all I was looking for was some seasonal doormats that I kept. I found a little box that said Angela's trailer. Jenna, I didn't even find this when we were writing our book. It had a blanket in it, a pillow. It had like some extra socks. Like who knows how long this little box has been in the way back of the shed,
but it had a journal that I kept in my trailer and I wrote in it in the pilot season one and season two. Oh my gosh, Angela! I know. This is such a fine. It's such a fine. I wrote about the basketball episode, lady. You did not. Oh, All of these specific things. I was like in journal overload.
I was like, oh my god, what am I going to share all this? This is all. But I'm going to wait. I'm going to save those for special things. I wrote about filming the pilot. I have little notes that like Oscar gave me, taped inside the journal. I have my call sheet, lady.
Wow. I know. And we found so much stuff when we did our book. Is it making you want to call the publisher and say no need? No, no. We need to do a reprint. No. So I'm not going to read from that journal today.
I thought I would save that journal for when we get to the end of the run. That's fun. Yeah. Okay. Because I also found a card you gave me. Oh. I know. So I'm going to save all that.
But today's Angela's journal, you guys, I have a journal that I titled Travel Journal. Oh, it's a travel journal. And I only wrote on it when I was on a plane or a bus or a train. And I guess guys, I really take inventory of who sits around me. You do, and when you travel, you leave me the most amazing messages about the people you were surrounded by. It's so entertaining
and detailed. Okay, well here we go, you guys. This is written at 5.56 pm on a flight from Philadelphia to Los Angeles. It was 2005. Okay. Okay. I have now been on this flight for three hours. I write 556 p.m. in all caps, bored exclamation point. And then I write, Ken Quapas, the director of the office, actually has a movie on this plane. It's the sisterhood of the traveling pants. It was the feature movie. I saw it with Jenna at the theater when it came out. So I didn't feel like paying five dollars for headphones, frowny face. Oh yeah. Now they give you headphones. Yeah. This is in 2005. I go on to say, and now the odd couple is on. And I wish I had a pair of headphones. The guy behind me is pounding Jack Daniels and Coke. I think he's finally passed out.
Oh, and the two ladies in front of me are feuding. One wanted the other to switch, so her husband could sit next to her, but the other lady said, no, she didn't want to give up her seat. It's been tense ever since. This is amazing. And this part cracks me up. The guy next to me has been diligently reading a book on Texas Holdham and furiously scribbling notes. He ran out of
paper and has started to write on his plane ticket. He keeps covering his notes with his hand, like I'm gonna steal his secrets. I'd offer him a page out of this journal, but he's such a grump. I'd offer him a page out of this journal, but he's such a grump. We should be landing in half an hour, and I'm starving, and there's no snacks on US Airways, unless you want to pay $7 ridiculous. What happened to the airline industry?
Question mark, exclamation point. That was amazing, Angela. Oh, you guys. I loved Oh, you got it. I loved it. I loved it. Can you believe I wouldn't give the guy a piece of paper? He's like writing on his plane ticket. You're not going to give the airline $5 for headphones or $7 for a snack.
You're not sharing your paper. I'm not going to spend $12 on things I need. No. Oh. Ridiculous. $. Oh, ridiculous. $7 for SNAP. I absolutely loved it. Well, there you go.
That's my Angela's journal's updates. I will save some of our early years that I wrote about for the end of our run. That's all I got for FastFacts Lady. I could really just do a whole episode of you reading your journals. You know what this made me want to do? Is journal again when I travel? Because I use to always do. Me too. Yeah. It's such good character study. If you're a writer or an actor, it's great character study. I always love your messages when you've gotten off a plane because that's what they are. That's the description I get. You really paint a picture. All right,
well, should we take a break? And then when we come back, does Stanley have a mustache? Oh, there's a hot debate. Well, the episode's going to start with Pam and Phyllis. They're passing around a card for everyone to sign, welcoming Stanley back from his tonsil surgery. I guess the card says, quote, glad they didn't mix up your tonsilectomy with a mustache ectomy. We get some Gymsass, he says, oh, that's not good. Met with some phyllisass, she's like, oh, because your jokes are all hilarious.
You know what, lady, this made me realize we really like a punny card on this show. Mm-hmm. Remember in the Alliance, Meredith got a card that said happy bird day? Yep. Do you have a memory of getting a real pun card? Because I do.
No, we give my dad pun cards. Does he like a pun card? He loves a pun. He's a punner. There's one in every family. Mm-hmm. I am not the punner, but somehow I still get cards with puns.
I got one time from a friend of mine that it was just a picture of a sofa and it said you're sofa king awesome Took me a second Clever Well Jim is going to question whether or not Stanley has a mustache. Yeah And everyone's like no he does have a mustache And everyone's like, no, he does have a mustache. Well, some people feel very strongly that he does. Some people feel like, no way he does not.
And then some people are waffling. I did break it down. Here's how the Dundermiflin bunch voted by show of hands. Team Stash are Pam Dwight Creed and Oscar. Team No Stash, Jim Phyllis Angela. Team Unsure about the stash, Kevin. I feel like Phyllis, Angela, team unsure about the stash, Kevin. I feel like Phyllis raises both hands. She has two hands up at the end.
Yes, that's true. She might be unsure. She might be in team unsure stash. I mean, Pam even draws a picture. She draws a mustache, Stanley, and a no mustache, Stanley. That didn't seem to help, but we did get a lot of mail about these drawings. Jocelyn V and St. George Utah, Millie P from Durham, North Carolina, and Zoe G from Irvine,
California, all said Jenna in the cold open when everyone is trying to remember whether or not Stanley has a mustache. Pantross two pictures of Stanley in eight seconds. That's very funny. At 50 seconds, she is standing next to Phyllis, and at 58, she says, okay, and then holds up two full-page recognizable sketches of Stanley. In rewatching the scene, Pam's frantic faux-speed sketching in the background of Jim's line had me cracking up. That means she only had four seconds for each of those pictures. Who really drew
those pictures? Were you directed to draw really fast? Please tell us everything you remember about this scene. Well, Jocelyn, Millie, and Zoe, I have a curveball to throw at you. What if Pam has sketched everyone in the office and keeps them in her desk drawer? That's something something Dwight would do. I know. Because he's gonna need a wand in the poster and a moment. But Pam has drawn Dwight. This is true.
Well, first of all, I did not draw those pictures. They were preset for me. I'm pretending to draw feverishly. But there were a few lines of dialogue in the scene that got cut out. The original script allowed me more time to draw these pictures. So in the scene, Pam says, Phyllis would know if Stanley has a mustache, she sits across from him every day. And Phyllis is like, oh my god, I don't know. Now I think he doesn't. And Pam
says, oh, come on, Phyllis, the whole card depends on this. So at this point, Jim would have thrown to Kevin. He would have said, Kevin does Stanley have a mustache. And Kevin would have said, okay, I'm picturing him. Now I'm asking him if he has a mustache. He's not answering guys. And also, Creed would have said, when I close my eyes, I see a mustache, and a white beard, and a red suit.
He's my father, and he's asking me to guide his sleigh tonight. So- Don't ask Creed ever. Don't ask Creed. The script did say that I was supposed to hold up to quote hastily made drawings. It also noted that the one with the mustache should be a giant mustache, not an accurate mustache.
So there you have it, that's what happened. I had more time, but they kind of snipped some of it away. You had more time, but still not enough to do those two drawings, in my opinion, but that's okay, it's a little bit of TV magic. I feel like I would have doubled my time. But that's okay, it's a little bit of TV magic. I feel like I would have doubled my time. Do you think 16 seconds is enough time?
It might have been more, because Kevin does a whole visualization thing. I don't know. Well, I guess it depends on your skill set because I would have needed all day to do that. Well Gabe is very excited because Stanley is arriving and as Stanley walks in, Gabe covers his face, so we can't see and then does sort of like tada and he does in fact have a mustache.
We got a fan question from Veronica R and Park City Illinois who said, where did the idea of Stanley having or not having a mustache come from? Was this based on a real conversation about whether or not Leslie had a mustache? Well, Veronica, we got to trade some messages with our writers Steve Healy, and he said that this idea came up in the writers room. He said it was either Mindy or BJ who pointed out that it was really hard to visualize whether or not Leslie had a mustache or not. He said that the writer's room did have a debate, and only about 85% felt 100% sure he had one. I thought this was so relatable when Steve shared this with us because how many times are you sitting around
like at dinner with friends that you've known forever? And someone's like, oh yeah, you know, Jenna has blue eyes and they're like, no she doesn't. Like what are you talking about? She has blue eyes and then that whole debate starts. Like, yeah, it happens. When I was watching the cold open, did it make you second guess?
It did. Me too. I was not sure. I was like, wait, no, he does. He does. He does. He does, yes. But you just plant that seed of doubt
and then you're sure. Yeah. Well Steve was so gracious. We reached out to him with a few questions and then you're sure. Yeah. Well, Steve was so gracious. We reached out to him with a few questions and we're going to sprinkle those in. Well, I've got something to share from him right off the top after the opening credits. We got a fan mill flurry again about Nelly
not being featured as the manager. Yes, I noticed that too. I thought for sure this opening credits would have something with her on her desk. But no. I asked you, he'll be about it. I said, did the writers have an arc in mind for Nelly as manager? And he said there was not a clear plan.
With the other managers, it was sort of pre-planned. They knew it was going to be an arc. He said they were kind of at this point writing week to week. Oh, geez. Yeah. Oh my gosh. He said he did remember talking to Catherine Tate one day at lunch early on, and she had shared that she found California kind of odd compared to London. So they did try to incorporate some of that kind of fish out of water stuff into her character. So that was something that they had pre-planned for her rival to Scranton. But they didn't know about Nellie's position within the Dundermiffland, like hierarchy. Or how long she would be staying manager. They were kind of deciding week to week. How that would go.
Got it. Well, Robert California is going to arrive and he's not greeted by anyone because Aaron is in Florida. He sneaks up behind Pam, who has headphones on. She's drinking her coffee, she's rocking out. Yeah, she is listening to Drake featuring Swiss beats. I have an audio clip. Would you like to hear what Pam was warming up? Wait, I know what she was warming up to, but I think we should all hear it.
It's fancy. Oh, I know. I know what she was warming up to, but I think we should all hear it. It's fancy. Oh, I know. Oh, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, head. Are you fancy, huh? Are you fancy, huh? Are you fancy, huh?
Are you fancy, huh? Are you fancy, huh? They're done here, done everything they did. They're done here, done everything they, oh, you fancy, huh? Are you fancy, huh? Are you fancy, huh? Are you fancy, huh? Are you fancy, huh? All right, that fancy, huh? Are you fancy, huh?
All right, that's how Pam warms up for a day of work. Yeah. It got me thinking, do you warm up with music, and I texted you, I said, I think we should each think about this, and we should play our warm up for the day music. 100%. You do? Oh, yeah. And sometimes if I think the kids,
you know, I have teenagers now need to pick me up on the way to school Maybe they got a big test. Maybe they got to get amped up. I am I do the carpool DJ stuff. I play some songs to get us going Oh wow you got your carpool playlist, but I'm it's the mom version. I don't know if it's exactly There's stuff. I have a good mix. I really do. Okay, what does your main go to? I really have to. Okay. That I love. I love Alicia Keys' girl on fire.
Mm-hmm. And I love a little Joan Jett. Hey, I'm a kid of the 70s, and Joan Jett really wakes me up. Like the song, Bad Reputation. Mm-hmm, I love it. Do you wanna hear a little bit of it? Yeah, let's hear it. reputation. I love it. Do you want to hear a little bit of it? Yeah, let's hear it.
I love it. I just added it to my playlist. Isn't it a good one? That is so good. You know, Lee wrote and directed a movie called Ordinary World, stars Billy Joe Armstrong and Joan Jett makes a cameo in it. It was also right around the time that both of them were inducted into the rock and roll Hall of Fame in the same year, like the same ceremony. Mm-hmm. Never got to meet her. All of this, right?
Lee has met her, worked with her. Rock and roll, man. Love her. Love her. Well, Jenna, what about you? Well, as you know, I mostly drive in silence. I know. I know this. But sometimes in the mornings, if I'm dragging or something, my go-to warm-up, pick me up, is the musical Hamilton. Oh, I love Hamilton. That's on our mix too. I will always end with the same song like as I'm getting close to home, I'll switch so that I end on room where it happened. Oh, I love it.
That's my major pump me up and I have a clip. Yeah about us, we're in the room where we're happening. Don't worry about us, we're in the room where we're happening. Don't worry about us, we're in the room where we're happening. Don't worry about us, we're in the room where we're happening. No one really knows how the game is played. The art of the trade, the sausage, it's made. We just assume that it happens. But no one else is in the room where it happens. I just love it. I love it so much. I've seen Hamilton on Broadway three times since it came out.
Once with the very original cast, the OG, the OG, I had to get the super expensive, terrible seats. You couldn't get a ticket. And I've seen it twice since with the current cast. The energy in the theater for this whole show is like I don't even know how to describe it. It's a body buzz. It is. It is. Especially now that pretty much everyone who goes knows all the songs. Yeah. And I've seen different people play all the different parts and it just delivers every time. Every time.
I love it too. I have to say also on my mix are a few songs from the musical six. Oh, yes! Yes, and I also love, if you don't have this on your playlist, I'm Every Woman by Shaka Khan. Sure.
Yeah, it's so good. Well now I feel pumped up actually. Me too. I feel especially pumped for the rest of this podcast. Robert gets distracted from his conversation with Pam because Nelly is going to finally arrive. He's giving Pam a speech about how the best work is done between 9 and 10 a.m. Nelly's going to walk in the door at 9.50. Yeah. She's going to say she hits snooze multiple times and finally woke up 10 minutes ago. There's a lot of back and forth between Nelly and Robert
and Angela and Pam are clocking it all. They are the biggest eye rolls. I mean, is that one of your eye roll memes, Angela, because it's not, it should be. It means to be. It's an IRL that I do kind of a weird thing with my mouth like, burr. It is delicious. I wrote a lot of big acting choices in this episode.
That's what I wrote, too. I want to do a fan catch here for you from Sophia D. and Hamilton, Ontario, Canada, who said that it, two minutes and 20 seconds, Nelly mentions that she snoozes her alarm clock in nine minute increments. Sophia said, this made me wonder why the snooze feature on alarm clocks are nine minutes long because it seems like such a random number.
So I did a mini deep dive. Oh, cool. Sophia's gonna tell us. Thank you, Sophia. I guess when they made the original alarm clocks, it wasn't possible to get the gear teeth to line up to make for an exact 10 minutes. So they chose nine instead,
but now iPhones and other clocks just carry on the tradition. Even though now you could get a snooze of 10 minutes, should we be able to choose our snooze? Yeah, you can. You can choose. Now I can choose my snooze? Well, you can set a timer, I guess.
What do you mean set a timer? Like you can say, I want to sleep five more minutes. You can? Yes. Clearly someone who hits snooze. Wait, so when I hit snooze, do I preset my snooze time? Because I don't want it in the moment, I'll wake up if I'm like having to... Yeah, no, I don't know about that. I just like do like the wheel, like I just spin it. I'm like, yeah, okay, 10 minutes.
I know that there's someone out there who knows how to operate their phone and they're dying because we are asking questions that they're answering. I think we do this often, lady. I think we have our moments and they're like, oh my gosh, you are our two old ants. Well, if you could change your snooze time from nine minutes to something else, would you? Probably not. I would maybe do seven. Seven, lucky number seven. You know why? Because I want a snooze twice,
but 18 minutes feels like too much snoozing, but maybe 14 minutes feels right to me. The fact that you're breaking it down like that tells me you're not a real professional snoozer. No, I very rarely snooze. Uh-huh. I don't see the point. I wait to have my alarm go off until the very last minute.
Well, Nelly is a snoozer. Wack, she hits it a lot. Robert says he thinks there's something more going on with her than just a lack of willpower, you know? Mm-hmm. And he's going to have Jim and Dwight help her move and get settled. He's concerned about her. And he's going to have Jim and Dwight help her move and get settled. He's concerned about her. Not only that, he's going to tell everyone in the office that at the end of the day, we're going to have a welcome party for her. So start planning.
Yeah, Robert is so invested in Nellie and her happiness. You know, when we were talking to Steve Healy our writer, he said in an early version of the episode, this episode was called, help me not to do her. What? Yes, it's not an episode. And it was all about Robert California trying to resist his attraction with Nelly and ordering Jim to help him with that temptation.
And then Steve put in all caps wisely, we went in another direction. I love that we get these nuggets from our writers. I know. That's incredible. And now we have some rapid fire back-to-back talking heads as Pam Jim, Pam Jim. They're like, why are we throwing a party for someone who's horrible?
Why is Nelly even here? Why is she here? There also would have been a Darryl talking head. OK. It was in the shooting draft, and it would have said, Andy took off to get Aaron. Nelly showed up to take Andy's job. Robert has a crush on Nelly.
And Darrell's new French cuff shirt goes unnoticed. Aw, Darrell. But then there were two candy bag ults that really made me laugh. Okay, the top of the talking head is the same, but it ends with this. And Darrell's got a front row seat, which he would happily give up to just about anybody.
And then his other candy bag all it was. And who's selling paper? That would be nobody. Oh, I love that line. I know. Now, we are going to join Andy and Aaron. They're in the car. They're driving back to Scranton.
They're so cute. Taylor M. from Brentswick, Georgia said, I love the callback to the season six episode murder where Andy asked Aaron out on a date in Savannah while as their murder mystery characters and now they're back together again and they're wearing their Savannah t-shirts. They finally had their date in Savannah. Oh, that's so true.
Such a cute callback. Cute callback, they're making up songs, you guys. Andy's gonna sing two crazy kids on the journey of life. Aaron's gonna chime in, go into Pennsylvania. All the hope in the world these two. They're gonna make a pit stop. They're gonna have a little lunch and they're gonna explain that they're on their way to Jessica's parents' cabin in Southern Pennsylvania. Andy thinks this is gonna be a good place to let her down easy. Her parents' cabin. Pennsylvania Andy thinks this is gonna be a good place to let her down easy.
Her parents cabin. There are so many moments in this episode where I thought, you know what? Andy and Erin belong together. I'm changing my mind. Jessica, you know what? You narrowly escaped. It's so true.
I have the location of the park. We got some mail. People were curious. This is a little bit of movie magic because this scene in the park, quote unquote, park was shot on the same property as the cabin. Oh, it was kind of right next to the cabin. That's perfect. Yeah. It's a place called Canyon Ranch in 1,000 Oaks. Aaron and Andy get back in the car, get on the road. Andy thinks maybe it's time for a little smoochy smooch,
but Aaron shuts that down. Uh-uh, buddy, not till you're officially single. Mm-hmm. So they got a wait. Yeah. We don't care. I know, we were team Jessica. So this episode made us angry.
It did, although I'm gonna have a moment where I turn on Jessica a little later. Okay, okay. So I just so everyone knows I can turn on her. Okay, I think I know the moment. All right, and I think they needed it because I think we had to start rooting for Andy and Erin. Up next in the break room, I titled this scene,
Mean Girls in the Break Room. And if anyone wants to write a pop song version about it and tag us, I will gladly play it. Phyllis Oscar-Pam and Angela are really gripping about having to throw a party for Nelly. And then Phyllis proposes maybe on purpose. They throw a bad party, like a really crappy party. Angela's like, ooh, maybe we should have the party right here in the break room and then they giggle. Phyllis says order carrot cake, they're laughing so hard.
Mm-hmm. I have 90 million catches from the scene. Let's go. Number one, when did Oscar join the PPC? I don't know. Okay. Number two is a fan question from Hannah G. in Scotland who says, I need a breakdown of Angela's hair in this episode. She has a curly bouncy ponytail which seems very fancy for Angela.
Was there an event going on this week that she had her hair this way or did you guys just decide to change it up? I noticed it too, and what is with your poofy? It is not flat ironed. No, it is leftover event hair. Okay. 100% and then Kim had to match it every day because we always got excited when I had leftover event hair.
Also did you catch at five minutes, 28 seconds, that my ponytail holder is the exact same color as my hair? I thought it was your hair. No. I thought they did a wrap around. No, it's a ponytail holder is the exact same color as my hair. I thought it was your hair. I thought they did a wrap around. No, it's a ponytail holder. I have a catch at five minutes and 30 seconds. What's that? I am not wearing my Pam engagement ring and wedding band.
I'm wearing a different ring. It looks like someone wore it home and left it at home. I don't know what I did. That would happen. Sometimes we would just leave set and I was like, oh no, I'm wearing Angela's earrings and her rings. Yeah, the wardrobe department had doubles
of everything for me for earrings and necklaces because I would do that so often. And then you know, you take them off at night to shower and you tell yourself, I'm gonna put this on in the morning. I'm gonna put this on in the morning. And then you leave. And now like Jenna, what happened? I also have a fan catch from Brenton A. in Marin County, California, who said, I have a St. Louis catch at four minutes and 41 seconds.
Phyllis proposes the idea of artoring some carrot cake. Arder. It falls right in line with popcorn and that's a big arder. She does. She wants to art her some carrot cake. Those are my catches. Every time you guys catch Phyllis having a St. Louis accent is one of my favorite things. I agree. Well lady, let's take a break because when we get back we're going to be Holland cube. Yeah, we should rest up. Mm-hmm. We are back and before we haul some cube, Andy and Erin are going to do some breakup scenarios in the car. Get a little role play. We had a fan question from Mallory C in Durham, North Carolina, who said, in the scene where Andy and Aaron are practicing for Andy's breakup with Jessica,
it looks like Ed broke and genuinely laughed when Ellie said, what is it I didn't sleep all last night? Was that scripted? Mallory it was not. It was improvised. I think they just let them go. They 100% just let them go. They 100% just let them go. If you are wondering where we shot the driving scenes, Wonder No More, first of all, Ed was not driving. We hooked up the car to a dolly
and it was pulled by an insert car that's lingo for like a flatbed truck. And in the back of the truck, we have all our crew, we have camera sound director, assistant director. My dad had a flatbed truck and in the back of the truck we have all our crew, we have camera sound director, assistant director. My dad had a flatbed truck. Did he ever pull a picture car? That's Lingo for he didn't. The car the actors are in. He pulled a lot of horse trailer. Sure. Farming equipment. But he also loaded up a bunch of my stuff and drove the flatbed truck with a trailer attached to it, and that's how I moved to LA. How much stuff did you take?
You had your stuff in the flatbed and in a trailer behind it? The trailer behind it? The truck is pretty small, pretty short, but he also had an extended trailer he would attach to it. But I moved here with just a suitcase, and I lived out of a suitcase, and then finally my mom was like, Bill, load up, we're gonna bring you some furniture. Oh, that was really nice.
I know. Well, this flatbed was large. I have a picture of it. We got the flatbed truck. We've attached a car to it. We also had a bunch of precision drivers who drive around the picture car so that everything stays really consistent. You'll notice the car's drive at the exact same
speed. There's not a lot of passing. Steve Healey said that getting all these driving scenes was way more complicated than he realized, because he was on set. The writer would always be on set. They were always more complicated. Always more complicated. It's a lot of moving parts.
And we shot this all on a real highway. I mean, I guess, obviously, right? We didn't build a highway. That should have gone without saying. We've done it before. We did it for Pam and Jim's engagement, but we did not do it this time. No, real road. Now everyone, we're going to haul some cube. Thank God I've been waiting to haul cube. I love this expression. I want to start saying it. I'm hauling cube. Every time I move from now on, I'm going to haul cube. I'm going to haul cube. I love this expression. I want to start saying it. I'm Hall and cube. Every time I move from now on, I'm going to Hall cube. I'm going to Hall cube. How much stuff has Nelly brought with her from Florida? I know. And it's just now arriving. A lot. She's unpacked nothing.
I just want to point out. I don't feel like she's ever going to unpack. I'm just going to say this. I think that Nelly just brings a bunch of boxes and one big comfy chair and that's it. She just digs in a box when she needs something. That's possible. Nelly's apartment was in a real apartment complex on Wilkerson Avenue in Valley Village. We did not build this set that we went on location for this. As Jim and Dwight helped Nelly, they're really struggling with one of her big oversized chairs. Dwight says, you know what? We'll work our magic, we'll make it fit.
Nelly's like, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, let's not go there. Nothing is more repellent than magicians. Bunch of grown men, waving ones, pulling bunnies out of body crevices. Magicians are repulsive next topic. This is a lot of information out of nowhere. Super passionate amounts of information that don't really apply to moving you into your apartment.
Well, Jim's going to use that information. Pam's going to call him on the phone and tell him all about their hilarious bad party plan. And Jim says, oh, bad party plan. And Jim says, oh, hire a magician. Trust me. Mm-hmm. Well, we asked Steve Healey if they had been planting a seed about this magician's storyline
with Nelly. Because remember in last week's episode when Nelly arrived in Scranton, she said she hated the Houdini Museum. I'm surprised she went. I don't think she went. I think she just knows it's there. Here's what Steve said. Steve said he doesn't really remember that they were intentionally
planning this whole magician's storyline. But he said there is some natural tension between comedians and magicians. Lots of comedy people start out as magicians are flirt with magic at some point. And comedians are also such skeptics they often get irrationally angry at magicians. And that might have been part of it. Steve said, I remember some of the writers in those days were going to the magic castle. Magic was a frequent topic in the room. I had no idea!
It's very funny. Isn't that? Well, remember I was a comedic magician. I performed my comedic magic show at Stand Up Knights. I still want to bring that back. I want to make it part of our live show. I want you to do your magic act. Of course! Why have I not been doing it?
I don't know. Done! Done! I still have the cassette tape of music, and I bought a, what do you call it? A tuxedo jacket with tails? With a vintage shop? I have it. I know the perfect moment in our live show. I love our live show.
This has to happen, and I think I will be your assistant on roller skates. I am so disappointed we are only just now thinking of it, but I am so happy that we did. We have to add it. Andy and Aaron are going to arrive now at Jessica's family cabin. It is so charming. In the shooting draft, there was a scene where Aaron and Andy notice as they pull up, there seems to be a lot of people there. It read like this.
Exterior rural cabin. Andy and Aaron pull up to the cabin. There are several cars there. Andy says, why are there so many cars here? Aaron says Jessica's parents must be rich. But you know what, the cars aren't that nice. Personally, I'd rather have two really nice cars than seven crappy ones.
Guess that's why I'm not rich." Andy says, hmm, this is weird. And then there's a knock on their car window. Well, the knock on the window is from Lauren, played by Sue Redman. She studied acting at the Steppenwolf Theatre in Chicago and studied improv at Second City, Chicago. And according to IMDB, fun fact, she played a nurse in the movie Contagion and accidentally lodged a prop piece of medical equipment in Matt Damon's right ear. How do you do that? I don't know. She misused the prop equipment. I suppose I she's giving him an
exam. And she lodged it in his ear. Yeah, I'm sure temporarily. Oh my God. You know what, this is exactly why I never, ever want to be on a medical show. I would do that. You might hurt somebody. I don't know. I just don't even know how you come back from that.
What is your end of the day, Convo like after a day like that? When you call your best friend. I don't know. You would not believe what I did to Matt Damon today. Yeah, that's how you would lead that combo. For sure. Well, Lauren's gonna tell them
that Jessica is not there. She's gone for a jog. This is right around the time when Erin and Andy realize that they've come upon a bachelor at party. She's wearing a veil in her hair. I would like to play a bullsh** card. What is it? Andy and Jessica are dating. They're in a full in her hair. I would like to play a bullsh** card. What is it?
Andy and Jessica are dating. They're in a full-on relationship. Right. How is it that Andy wouldn't know that her good friend's getting married and they're gonna be having this bachelorette thing at the cabin? How?
I hear you. You know, he knows she's at the cabin, but he doesn't know why. She's just there solo. Is he a bad listener? You know, did Jessica say, hey, this weekend I'm gonna be up at my parents' cabin. I'm hosting. I'm hosting.
Yeah, I'm hosting the LaWripp party. It's kind of stressful. I have to buy extra groceries. Extra gummy penises. The gummy penises and a veil. And we have to have games. I'm gonna blow up a bunch of balloons. But people's names on them. Tape it to a poster board.
I'm very busy. I mean, that's how I communicate with Lee. He'd know all the deets. He'd know everything. We got a fan question from Santa M. in Houston, Texas, who said, where was Jessica's cabin actually located? It looks a lot like East Coast cabins. Well, I'll tell you, we shot this at a filming location called Canyon Ranch.
It is in the Santa Monica Mountains. It's just a film location. They have tons of different cabins and houses and they have a fake gas station and a fake saloon. I looked all over the website. The cabin we used was fully decorated. If you go to the website, it looks exactly the same. This location has been used for all kinds of films and commercials. A lot of car commercials. I have a question for you. Yeah.
Has it been used for a horror movie? Because I always feel like places with lots of capins are where all the shit goes down. I am sure. But if you go to the website, they have a lot of rugged terrain. So you know the shot of people driving off-road to set up camp at a creek. Yeah. Canyon Ranch. Got it. Yeah. I saw a lot of those on the website. I didn't see any horror
movies, but I'm sure. Right. I wonder if Cabin in the Woods was shot there. We'll never know. I'll never know. I'm not detective. We'll never know. Well, Steve Healey said that the cabin they filmed at had some really kooky angles. Oh, yeah. And it was very challenging to get some of the shots. He also said that he didn't think the Santa Monica Mountains looked much like Pennsylvania, but our writer, Danny Chun,
is from that area and vouched for it. I thought it looked authentic. And the fact that the cabin came fully furnished probably means that we didn't move stuff around, which was challenging for us. Mm-hmm. I see that. Back to Nellie's apartment, Dwight is unpacking things, and he wonders out loud if King-Sai Sheets are called presidential in England, and he really wishes he had a Twitter account.
Let me tell you what happened to me after this comment. Let me guess something to do with either bedding or Twitter. Bedding, okay. I wanted to know what our king size sheets called in England. What are they called? Well, the sheet sizes and bed sizes in England are called single double king king super king and emperor. Oh. Mm-hmm. Yeah. And none of them directly coordinate with American sizes.
So if I bought a queen size bedding set and moved to the UK, it would not throw it in the trash. Throw it in the trash. Maybe cut it up, use it for rags. Well, it's not going gonna fit on your bed. What am I doing, cutting up bedshoes? If you rank the large beds by size, here's the order it would go in from smallest to largest. Okay. King, that's the smallest of the large beds.
Okay. It goes king, super king, California king, Emperor. The two beds that are closest in size is the British, super king, and the American, California king. They're both 71 inches wide, but the California king is much longer. Yes.
Then the super king. The Emperor bed is seven feet wide and seven feet long. It's humongous. Who's sleeping in that? Professional basketball players, I think. Not people, I guess. I googled it. The average professional basketball player is six six.
So this Emperor Bed would be perfect for them. Yeah. I can't believe I know that. I mean, I really googled so much on this one, lady. Hey, get ready for your next cocktail party. You're going to be a delight. Guess what? There are more king beds than you could have ever imagined. In America, there is more than just the king and the California king. There is the Alaskan king, the Wyoming king, and the Texas king,
and they're all bigger than the California King. The Wyoming King is the same as an emperor bed in the UK. The Alaskan King is the biggest bed. It is 9 feet by 9 feet. It runs anywhere from $3,500 to $10,000. I found a website called AlaskanKingBeds.com. They sell these beds, bed frames, and sheets, and bedding. In the photo, there is a family of six
and their full-size golden retriever dog all sitting on this bed with plenty of room to spare. It looks like a small swimming pool. It's so big. But what size of room is it in? That's the problem, right? Yeah. Big room, I guess.
I mean, I guess if I'm a professional basketball player, I got a sweet pad, and I need a lot of leg room. Yeah. I mean, remember those shows? Was it on MTV where it was like, you went and got to see people's houses? Was it called like, Cribbs or something? Yeah.
I loved those. I saw Shaq Hyloneel's house. Maybe he had the Alaskan King. Did he have a big bed? He did. But it was like a giant circle bed. It was like a huge circle. Did your list include any big king-sized circle beds? Not specifically, that would be a custom bed, and it did say in the article that many NBA players have custom beds made for themselves to best fit their size.
Oh, well, Shaquille and Neil had one. And you know what, it had a giant Superman blanket on it. Oh. Yeah. In fact, this whole house had Superman stuff everywhere. Like the logo would be in the garage, on the shower doors, in the hedges. So yeah, he likes the theme. It was a nickname and he really leaned into it.
Superman was one of his nicknames. Yes, kind of makes sense. It does make sense. It's a shotgun Superman. And maybe he flies with the ball. Yes, Angela, in the clutch, he flies with the ball. Oh, because he's clutch. He's the clutch.
Yeah, he's of the team. He's the Superman clutch. He's lying with the ball. He's the SC of the clutch. Yeah, he's of the team. He's the Superman clutch. He's lying with the ball. He's the SC of the game. Oh, can you imagine us like being sports commentators? We would be so bad. I cannot. Oh gosh.
Anyway, okay, I'm so sorry, back to your king size beds. That's it. Okay. That's what I got. A lot of these very, very large beds are for family sleeps. People who like to co-sleep in one great big bed as a family. Okay.
And also your dog, I guess. Your giant dog. Your small Shetland pony. You could. A hundred percent put a small Shetland pony in this bed and still have room for your family of sex. Michael Scott could have slept at the foot of this bed and never even bothered Jan. A hundred percent this would have solved all their problems.
No bench needed. Jim and Dwight are now gonna find a shoebox that says do not open. So of course, what do they do? They open it. Dwight's going through all the pictures. Mm-hmm. I asked Steve Birch's, who is the man in the pictures? This was a background performer that they hired. He and Catherine had a big photo shoot on Monday morning of this week. It went from 7 to 9 a.m. and they changed their wardrobe.
They take a picture, change clothes, take a picture. It's very, very tedious to do these prop photos like this. But that's what they did. They had a two-hour photo shoot to get all these pictures. Nelly is going to walk in and find them going through the shoe box and she says, oh, I see you found Benjamin. But Benjamin isn't the name of her ex-boyfriend. It's the name of the box that contains pictures of Henry. That's right. Her ex-boyfriend. box that contains pictures of Henry. That's right, her ex-boyfriend. And this is when she's going to share with them all about this tragic breakup. Yeah. She had to sell their home at a loss. Yeah. And then there's a photo of Nelly and Henry and he's got a, looks like a magician's cape and they're like, is this for Halloween? And she goes, no, that's the worst of it. He's the magician.
Da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da- she cried, she said, please don't tell anyone back at work about this. It was a vulnerable moment. So Jim tries to call Pam, tells her to call off the pranks, cancel the magician at least. Yes. So in the shooting draft, the main girls in the break room scene actually was mid-process. They were still trading horrible ideas and Pam leaves to take the phone call and comes back. But there was a whole added beat where they're still trading ideas and Pam leaves to take the phone call and comes back. But there was a whole added beat where they're still trading ideas before Pam gets the phone call. And Angela actually gets very tickled and she gets the giggles.
In the shooting draft it says Angela giggles into her hands. It's indelated scenes if you guys are curious what it sounds like when Angela Martin gets the giggles. Let's hear it. I got one. Let's pretend that we thought it was her birthday and get her a cake with a few too many candles on it. Like 49.
Pam! That is brilliant! Well this is new. So this one are we a gaysha? What the? Wow. Wow! I mean, I remember doing that. So, what are we at Gaysha? What the? Wow. Wow.
I mean, I remember doing that. I remember brainstorming with Ed and Steve about what does it look like when Angela's this tickled. So, they had me cover my face with my hands almost kind of like what Mindy does when she gets tickled. When she actually laughs. When she actually laughs and is trying not to break on camera. And then they just said, Angela, just like a high-pitched kind of giggle over and over. So I did. I was just like, and anyway, it was cracking us up. It was kind of like the moment when we learned Angela eats like a squirrel. You know, lady when Pam does come back in the
break room after her phone call with Jim at 11 minutes and 22 seconds, I am now wearing my Pam engagement ring and wedding band. They're back on. Someone caught it. Someone found it. Pam is gonna try to get them to call off this prank party and no one is having it. Yeah. Yeah. Toots, we're not stopping this train, so get off the tracks, Phyllis says.
That's right. In the shooting draft, one of the things that Pam tells Jim is you need to stall. Like, if she's going to like rearrange this party, he's got to stall. And this scene made it into deleted scenes, Jim trying to stall. And we learned some new things about Nelly.
I thought you might like to hear it. All right, then. Let's get going. All right oh you know what though house really isn't a home until we've made some memories here some conversations. So let's sit back down and let's mix them. No we've got work to do back at work. Okay well I think British Idol is worse than American Idol. Thoughts? I would know I don't go for all that cheesy reality stuff. Okay. More of a survivor fan. Right. Well, I think that cricket is a stupid version of baseball.
Woo! Everything is a stupid version of something. A bike is a stupid car. A baby is a stupid adult. Come back to the office. I've got a list. Nelly's stupid. Would you mind giving me a piggyback on the way down?
Piggieback. Piggieback is a stupid version of the fireman's carry. Hello. I think British food is gross. That was delightful. Uh-huh. I loved every minute of that. Nellie is a survivor fan. She also has a list of stupid and I asked if he really I was like, please tell me you guys pitched Nellie's list of stupids. He said, I'm sure we did. He said, I couldn't find it. But she has a lot on her list. I have to imagine that Nellie's list of
stupids took up like a good two hours of one of their evenings. I feel like they just would have loved pitching on that. We are back at the cabin. The bachelor party is playing a game. And rather than Andy asking Jessica to step outside with him while he has a private conversation with him, they have instead decided to join the Bachelor at Party. Again, they're meant to be together. I've done a 180. Because
the two of them together make horrible choices. I know. This is why the balance with Jessica was so important, or whatever, we've said it so much. We're gonna let it go. Let's also point out that the Bachelorette's have been day drinking and this party is amping up. They're popping balloons of all the X's
that have done her wrong and making speeches. First balloon to go is John. I also saw Matthew Greg, Mike, and some other name that started with the C. They're really going to get into it. Aaron's getting anxious. She's like, I don't know about all this. And he's like, hey, it's going to be fine. Just act natural. Do you want a gummy penis? And she said, no, there's also like a bowl of gummy bears. And Andy goes these are delicious and Aaron goes but their penises. Mm-hmm. Lord help me I googled gummy penises.
These are a mainstay of Bachelorette parties. I've never seen one. What? Sam? Cassie have you seen a gummy penis? Oh yeah, of course. I haven't. Okay, it's like, what's Sam?
And John are like duh, of course. Yeah,'t. Okay, it's like, for Sam and Jen are like, duh. Of course. They're with penis straws and all the bachelor's. You haven't seen like the gummy penis straws. I've seen a penis straw. I've never seen a gummy penis. But guess what? You can buy him on Amazon.
The ones I found are called jelly willies. But oh man, guys, there's so much. There's penis-shaped chocolates. Lots of lollipops cakes I wondered if any of these items were sold at the penis museum in Iceland are they? It does have a gift shop. I couldn't see what all was at the gift shop But the penis museum has a cafe and they serve Oreo coconut penis waffles and they have a seasonal Christmas penis waffle What's that? It's a waffle shaped like a penis.
But it's seasonal, so is it like pumpkin spiced? Or Christmas spiced? Yeah, what's the season? It looks like it has strawberries and whipped cream. That doesn't scream Christmas to me. Well, listen, I'm not gonna argue with the people in Iceland about their penis waffles.
You're not? No. I'm gonna call someone up. I'm gonna let them have it. Really berate them about it. Oreo coconut penis waffle. Sounds'm gonna let them have it. Really berate them about it. Oreo coconut, penis waffle. Sounds delicious. A lot going on.
I love how surprised you are by all of the penis there's a whole industry of penis desserts. Yeah, out there. Maybe there's some savory penis stuff. I didn't see any penis crackers. Someone get on it. Penis potato chips, they're probably out there. I don't know. I only found desserts. I don't know why that's so funny to me. There's a whole untapped market.
Yes, that's what you're saying. Something get on it. At this point, Megan, who was played by Dana Powell, you might recognize her from Bridesmaids or the good place or modern family, she's going to come up to Andy and just give them a bunch of big bear hugs and say, you know, he's nothing like these awful X's and she wants him to sing. She wants him to sing for everybody. Dana is hilarious. And the shooting draft, it said her name was Megan R. There were two maigants, I guess. And she was the quote, drunken rugby girl. Dana and I have known each other a long time. She you have. Yeah, yeah. We did improv at iOS together. She's someone that just is instantly
hilarious, like makes really strong choices right away and is so freaking funny. She was great in this episode. I know. I love everything she did. I know. We had a fan question from Rose T. and Canada, who said, when Andy starts to sing a song, I'm not sure if you're familiar with the song, but it's called Lock Lomond, and it's an old Scottish folk song. The story is sorrowful, but the song is so beautiful and full of hope. It makes me feel that I'll always be able to find a way home, and it reminds me of my Scottish ancestry and the land that my ancestors were forced to leave behind. I highly recommend listening to the whole song.
Do you know who chose that song for Andy to start singing? Was it Ed or one of the writers? Well Rose, that was scripted. And I did take your advice and I went and listened to the whole song and I have a little audio clip for us because it is really truly beautiful You thought you weren't gonna hear more music today, but you are. This is our music episode. I am so excited because Rose I have been to Lock Lomond. Hey, I have stayed at Lock Lomond. I've been on a boat on Lock Lomond. It's beautiful. I want to hear the song I want to hear the song. Love will never meet again On the bunny-bunny bane Star-flag-loom-man
Oh, you take the high road And I'll take the low road And I'll be in Scotland land of foe, but me and my true love will never meet again on the bunny-bony bane of Locke Loma. Isn't that beautiful? It is beautiful. That was Peter Hollins.
Well, I loved it, and Lock Loman is gorgeous. I will share a picture. In our stories. Yes, that are now highlighted. Rose, thank you so much for writing in about that. Well, the Mean Girls Party is about to start. Pam's like, listen, if you're going to be mean, just try to be subtle. Darryl suggests they have a code name for Nellie.
I have two favorite lines from this episode, and the first one is in this couple of dialogue. Okay. Daryl says, in the warehouse, we use code names for people we want to talk about. Andy was jelly roll, Mike was Dennis the Menace, Ryan was douchebag. Ryan says, hey, that's not a code name, that's just an insult.
And here's my favorite line, Oscar says, plus everyone would know who you met. And here's my favorite line, Oscar says, plus everyone would know who you meant. And then Ryan goes, yeah, I know. It made me laugh. It was so perfect. The code name Pam pitches is Mondays. Everyone is annoyed with Mondays, right? Ryan, who I think still really doesn't like Pam, says, no, let's use the codename Pam and everyone agrees. I don't know if you notice, but at 13 minutes and 37 seconds, the top of Angela's ponytail is a mess. There's hairs going everywhere. That's because in the shooting draft, there was a scene where Meredith comes into the break room and is delighted by what she sees.
She turns to Angela and says, the break room, what kind of crap party is this? Angela smiles mischievously at Meredith. Meredith puts her in a headlock, says, oh, was this you kiddo? And gives her a nugie. Oh! And then Angela shoves Meredith away. And that's why her hair's a mess.
Very interesting. Well, Nelly's going to and they're gonna start with Creed serenading her. Mm-hmm. He says, get comfy. This first song is over 30 minutes long. Oh my gosh, lady. I remember us cracking up.
I know. There was a candy bag alt for this. Okay. And it's so funny. Creed would have, instead of saying the song is 30 minutes long, he would have said, the first song is audience participation. When I say go, you all start moaning like you're dying or something. Wow. Can you imagine? I have a fun fact about the guitar that Creed is playing.
Is it his actual guitar? It's his personal guitar. It's a limited edition replica of Robert Johnson's 1926 Gibson L1. Robert Johnson was an American blues musician and songwriter. If you go to Creed's house, he has a wall of guitars and mandalins and a banjo and the man like Ed, he can just pick up anything with strings pretty much and play it. Yeah. We're going back to the cabin again now, and Aaron tells Andy, I think we should leave. But Andy says, I'm gonna get this breakup over with. He pulls Jessica aside finally. He's babbling and she says, wait a second,
are you dumping me? Are you dumping me for Aaron? You said she wasn't relationship material and she wasn't as good as me. Jessica, this is not you, Jessica. Jessica, you're doing a low blow here, lady. Not cool. I had a turn here, not cool.
What Andy and Erin are doing is not cool, but that was not cool. But at the same time, she's pissed off, lady. Who knows what you would have said? True. You might have, like, listen. I'm not cool. But at the same time she's pissed off lady. Who knows what you would have said. True. You might have like, listen. I'm not Jessica. I know. I know Jessica is better than this comment. We have put Jessica on a pedestal. But I do think lots of us, maybe in that moment, would have been like, are you f***ing kidding me right now? Mm-hmm. I think that would have been better than these low blows to Erin in this moment.
And he starts to panic. He's like, blah, blah, blah, blah, no, no, no, wait, wait, okay, you want honesty, super honesty time? I'm gay. Mm-hmm. And Jessica's like, what? Yeah, her gay friend Kenny claims to have known this all along. He's like, I knew it.
Jessica says, Andy, you're not gay. I mean, when we were together, you seemed pretty excitable. And he's like, well, I was faking it. I had to fake it every time. Yeah, he imagined he was in a steam room with John Stamos. Jessica then says, I can't say it doesn't make sense. And then she says, look, you know what, Andy, it's fine.
I didn't think we were gonna get married or anything. I'm just, I'm just upset for now. There's the Jessica we know. Yeah, there's fine. I didn't think we were gonna get married or anything. I'm just upset for now. There's the Jessica. We know. There's the Jessica we know. I wanna give a shout out to Kenny who was played by Greg Worswick. He was a main company member
at the Groundlings in Los Angeles. He's been in Bridesmaids, Curbian Thusiasum, Superstore, Parks and Rec, and crossover connection with you and Brett Gellman, fresh off the boat. Hey! Is fresh off the boat, and crossover connection with you and Brett Gellman fresh off the boat. Hey, is fresh off the boat our new crossover connection? Maybe. Sorry, Monk. Might be. Well, Andy and Erin are now really awkwardly going to leave the cabin. You can tell Erin,
you know, those comments stung. Yeah. And now she's wondering what all Andy said about her. She's going to kind of just start to shut down. Mm-hmm. She's going to take a nap. Well, she saw a lot of turkeys and it made her tired. Yeah. Andy's picking up on these cues. He really didn't handle that well. And now he hasn't set himself up to succeed with Aaron.
And he wants to do right by it. At least right by Aaron, not so much right by Jessica, so he turns back around. He goes back to the cabin. And he wants to tell Jessica the truth, and here it is. He's in love with Aaron. She's totally relationship material. Aaron is so happy. She is beaming.
Jessica and her friends literally yell and chase them to the car, throwing, it looks like wedding cake at them. And they peel out and drive away and they're so happy. Yeah, and they finally kiss. Yeah, yeah. Jessica's friends are gonna talk about Andy for a long time. I feel like on her gummy penis weekend,
Bachelorette party, there's gonna be a big balloon labeled Andy. They sure is. Up next is maybe one of my favorite scenes. We filmed for the whole season. This, I mean, we laughed so hard. Okay, so here's what's going on. We're back in the mean girls in the break room party.
And everyone is giving a toast, but the toast are really mean-spirited towards Pam. Quote on Quote Pam. And it ends with everyone chanting, we hate Pam. Mm-hmm. And that's when our magician enters. Yeah. He offers to make Pam disappear.
Poof. Yeah. Where do we even start with the scene? I don't know. John Krizinski had to stand right next to Brett Galman, and this was a mistake. Mistake. This was a noodle moment for John.
A full noodle. He couldn't even stand. I scoured the season eight bloopers hoping that they would be in there and they are not. They are somewhere. Dave Rogers has got to have them. I was so thankful that I was off camera. I will. First of all, wait, before we get ahead of ourselves. Did you
know in the shooting draft this character's name was called Magic Mark. I didn't. Okay so the scene was extended and he would have had this introduction moment where he came in the room. It read like this. Okay everyone so my name is Magic Mark. I used to be a Magic Marker and then he holds up a magic marker. And then he says, but then I got rid of, he produces a DVD of E-R and says, the E-R, magic! And he made it disappear. Oh!
And it says that Jim Clarksnelly, who has a very tight smile, she's not a fan of magic mark. Here's the amazing thing about this, which is that we did not hire a magician. Instead, Brett Gilman had to kind of learn some of this slight of hand on the fly, like the little exploding fire thing in the hand. Steve Burgess says that's actually a really easy one. But when you see him in the episode when he brings the dove, the bird,
it was so awkward and clumsy every time. It was so, it was never good. And we couldn't get through that moment. Look what I wrote, what? We could not get through this moment. No, every time that bird appeared. It was so ridiculous. And it was so close to John to you.
Oh my God. Well, magic mark is going to ask Nelly if she would like to be his special volunteer for the day, but Jim is gonna step in and he's gonna start sabotaging the act. Yeah. And then Pam is also gonna get in on this sabotage. My second favorite line of the whole episode
is when Robert turns to Dwight and says, why is Jim treating the magician poorly? Yeah. There's also a moment when Brett as the magician looks at Jim and goes, what the hell, man? I'm gonna clean show. This was the second thing that we couldn't get through because it's just this like burst
of anger. He's been holding it together the whole time. We also lost it when he singled out Phyllis. Yes. When he said, all right, where's Phyllis? Who's Phyllis? Look, this is really uncool, okay? You can see Phyllis laughing.
You can see her laughing. Yeah. And then Dwight says, scram wizard. And then they argue all the way out the door down the hallway, that was not scripted. Oh, amazing. They were just, you was just supposed to get them out of the room,
but the two of them, I don't know if you remember Jenna, kept yelling at each other as they left. It was so good. So good. Sometimes I think about what days would I go back? I would go back to the shoot. I would as well. I also think about characters days would I go back? I would go back to the shoot. I would as well.
I also think about characters I wish had come back and I would have loved to see more of Magic Mark. Like maybe he really pisses Dwight off because they're in the same Dungeons & Dragons group. I don't know. Yeah. The way Dwight said Scram Wizard, you kind of felt like they had history.
You know, Nelly is really touched by this magician sabotage. She gives a very touching speech. She thinks everybody is a brilliant employee in their own way. Robert agrees. He says, great party. This party is maybe one of the most successful PPC parties. And they tried to make it the worst. What does that say about this group? How is this one of the best PPC parties? Well, usually when they throw a party for someone,
the person does not enjoy their birthday or their day. They usually are like, this is the worst party I've ever been to. Nelly loved her party. Okay, so by that, I guess it was a success. Also, I just wanna say I like a carrot cake and I would not be disappointed to eat a carrot cake at a party there. Do you know how much butter and cream cheese is in a carrot cake so much? So much. It can't help it be delicious.
I love it. A red velvet cake that everybody always cuvets and loves. It's really a cousin to the carrot cake. Sort of similar. So maybe listen, get your penis mold, put some carrot cake in it. That's a great cake. It's a great party cake.
It sure is. Well, this episode is gonna end with some Hank's ass. Pam and Jim are leaving for the day and Pam goes up to Hank and says, I thought I was very specific about you not letting up a magician. Hank said, I have my eyes open. Jim's like, actually, he made it up there. Pam's like, yeah, he came and went. And then Hank has this great pass of aggressive sass moment where
he's like, wait a minute. You said it was a magician, right? You don't think he could have used. It couldn't have been. And Pam's like, you know what, let's just go. Let's go. Mm-hmm. Hank's ass. Hank's ass. Well folks, that's welcome party. We want to give a big shout out to Steve Burgess and Steve Healey for all their extra tidbits in this one. And thank you guys for writing in. You had such great observations and comments and questions. It just really opens up the episodes, we love them.
We will be back next week! See you then! Bye! Thank you for listening to Office Ladies! Office Ladies is produced by Earwolf, Jennifer Fisher and Angela Kinsey. Our senior producer is Cassie Jerkins. Our in-studio engineer is Sam Keeper. Our editing and mixing engineer is Jordan Duffy, and our associate producer is Ainsley Bubbaco.
Our theme song is Rover Tree by Creed Bratton. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.